does jen sack you ever call you does she
ever call you
does you guys ever talk at all or no we
don't i mean like i
i know that she's kind of
not mentioned me by name but she's
alluded to some of the stuff i've said
like during her press conferences she
will kind of throw shade at us um she
likes hating on florida but i think i
know why though i know why can i make my
speculation this is pure speculation so
remember 50 50 world we're following
with the speculation
uh
i don't know how much you work every day
i think you probably work 30 minutes a
day you and let me explain to you why i
think jensac is jealous of you because
jen sackey is probably working 24 hours
a day having to fix everything biden
does 24 7. i think for you your job is
easy desantis gets up on camera you're
like
okay that makes sense all right this
makes sense
i feel like your job is a pretty easy
job today that's on point i mean look
and i mean in the most respectful way i
don't mean it in a way i get what you
mean because he says what he means he he
fact checks everything he says before he
says it so i don't have to play clean up
like jen does with with president biden
but also you know my job is harder in
one way which is the media the media i
mean most mainstream media is totally
against desantis and they're totally
pro-biden
it's there are exceptions of course but
i think so our jobs are easy and
difficult but for different reasons
are you saying the local media or the
national media local media is much more
fair in florida because i think they
they know what's going on here they live
here right and they have access to the
governor they can ask him questions and
everything so so they've treated us more
fairly the national media has its own
totally own agenda and and they
try to they go out of their way to cover
for biden i think they have to they have
to do that because when but by the way
to be fair to her how much she's working
and saki i i don't think
saki is working any harder than sean
spicer had to work or sarah huckabee
sanders or caitlyn mcinanny very tough
jobs defending trump and biden no
there's no question about it okay
kellyanne
yeah but by the way that's why i
have so much respect for kellyanne
conway i think kel you know who
kellyanne conway is
kellyanne conway is trump's dennis
rodman okay
she has to do the dirty job she's got
the hair she's an elbow and she's gotta
turn him in there and get dirty i was
like michael you just go i got you man
don't worry about it i got you you know
he goes up and does what he does are you
a fan of kellyanne conway who are you a
fan of because you said you're a
conservative you're you're female you
know you're blonde like kelly and you're
not throwing that out there but is there
somebody
in the press secretary world or
spokesman world for politicians you're
like
kellyanne conway that's my girl or
you know saki or anyone who who is your
role models in this in this uh in your
job honestly i i like kellyanne i think
she did a great job i think kaylee mac
and he did a fantastic job i love that
she was
you know polite but firm with the press
and she always had the facts on her side
like you can't just like hit back at the
press by calling them names you have to
have the facts and so that's what i
liked about her um sarah sanders was
also really good so you know there's a
lot of folks that i think are good
spokespeople sake is a good spokesperson
i don't agree with her on anything but
she can spin and her job is hard because
like remember last week biden said that
a minor incursion of russia into ukraine
is is okay basically and she had to work
to walk that back i mean that's
a tough job i totally agree i actually
think i'm i think as ability-wise i
think jane is actually good at her job
well like what tough job it's a tough
job how much leeway do you have meaning
does he say look this is the script
whether it's trump biden desantis you're
his mouthpiece it's not like he's coming
on and doing the pbd podcast yet but
you know you have to represent them how
much you say listen i trust you just do
your thing you know we've talked about
this or it's like stick to the script
this is what it is if you screw up we're
gonna come like
how does it work your job well i think
it's different for every politician but
with governor desantis i'm really lucky
because i do get a good amount of leeway
what that means is though
i have a high expectation of me too that
i can't just go injecting my own
opinions if it's different or like going
off script and talking about stuff that
has nothing to do with what he's doing
as governor right but i think it's
helpful that i actually agree with him
on everything i don't know that i could
be defending a boss that i didn't agree
with i think it would be a very
difficult job in that case but because i
do agree with him i think it's easy also
he's very um active like he gives press
conferences almost every day he gives or
like a speech or something like he
speaks almost every day and so there's
just a lot of content to go off of i
know what he would say about something
like all of these big issues he's asked
about it a lot he does interviews
frequently and so like there's i i just
pretty much know what his responses
would be so if i can base my responses
on what he has said but i can add my own
flair to it you know like and i actually
i feel like i have more of an ability to
hit back when there's like fake news or
when there is a personal attack from
nicki freed if the governor hits back it
elevates that person but me as a
spokesperson as a staff member like i
can do it and not risk that same like
elevation yeah you're the flat carrier
you're playing the role of a flag killer
dennis rodman she she is a friendly
dennis rod but i'm telling you that is
by far if you ever build a team you have
to have somebody that is a little bit
you know it's willing to get i think how
much
fire and under pressure kellyanne conway
had to deal with and she was why would
you say that i mean trump has to be one
of the biggest sweethearts we've had as
a president in the last however long so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]